what what are your favorite promises
that he's kept well he's given us
two supreme court justices he's about to
give us number three which is acb
uh i believe we're up to over 200 uh
federal judges which are lifetime
appointments
i like that he cut the corporate tax
because just thinking logically for a
second let's think logically
when we're talking about corporate tax
if china has a corporate tax of
20 and america has a corporate tax of 30
if you're a business where are you
strategically gonna go
you're probably gonna go to china
because it's lower and you can get
better business right
i believe that he's lowered our
corporate tax to 15 or something like
that so that's bringing businesses
back to america it's incentivizing
businesses to come
along with territory and we're tariffs
and you know what
i'm sorry but i'm not a free trader i
want to make it very clear
i'm a fair trader and you can be a free
trader all you want
but if other countries are imposing
penalties and tariffs on
us and we are not imposing penalties and
tariffs back on them
i call that stupidity i think that is
dumb that we are not playing on a
fair uh battleground versus other
countries why are we letting them rip us
off
and why are we rewarding them with our
business
to rip us off that makes no sense
they're extract
our industries are being extracted thank
you and it was dylan radigan who said
that like 10 years ago on msnbc
said oh many many criticisms for the
democrats and the republicans but he
mentioned that
our our jobs are being extracted through
trade yes and that was
that was like 2011. that was amazing
we've seen it we have people in america
who it then becomes ian's job as an
american
at a company to train his
counterpart across the country to do his
job for
the world you mean other countries in
the world
and we've seen that and you know i love
that he's securing the border
illegal immigration is a big big issue
for me
and i think it plays into black lives
matter because in our country
we have 3.6 million black children
living in poverty
we have 4 million hispanic children
living in poverty and we have 4.2
million white children living in poverty
so how can you in a straight face say to
me black lives matter
while the democrat party is taking care
of illegal immigrants
over black lives if you care about black
lives
put the black community first so i'm a
big proponent of
stopping illegal immigration i support
our police i support
defending not defunding our police and
you know this issue isn't very popular
to some because i know it's not
necessarily america first
but i think it's important to show
president trump is the only president
keeping his promises clinton bush
obama trump all promised they would move
the u.s embassy to jerusalem
and who was the only president in all of
those years to keep his promise
president donald trump and what did the
media say when he did
racist or oh no they said it's 20 years
later
world war three it's gonna iran's gonna
launch the ships and then syria
and what happened nothing happened
nothing oh wait wait now we're getting
peace with bahrain
now we're getting peace with the uh the
emirates the uae
saudi arabia oh but where's the nobel
peace prize for donald trump even though
he's been uh
he's been nominated for three now just
fine he might get one
i don't think so they're not gonna give
that no they've never had any american
that chooses it so he might
it's not an honor anyway it has been the
fact that president obama i think within
his first year received the nobel peace
first nine months so crazy it was so and
meanwhile he's bombing
everything i don't but i don't i don't
blame obama for that he got nominated by
somebody
we don't blame him he was like in the
process right right right
the pulitzer if he were if he were
honorable you know what i would have
done
i would have as president obama i would
have said i'm
so humbled and honored by this but i
cannot at this time
accept this award and i would like to
fulfill
my campaign promises to you a piece and
then i will he could have done it in
such a classy way when he first
when he first got into office he kept
saying how much he admired abraham
lincoln
and he was ready to make some move and
get assassinated and change the world
but you don't have anybody's you didn't
have anybody's
support the american people just say
dude hey our like we're talking about
the american people we're like our guys
in we're done we're they walked away yet
and then you know obama when he started
talking about his favorite guy was teddy
roosevelt
he had a big obama so in four years he
realized i'm not going to do the lincoln
thing
i like teddy yeah he got in he was like
you know i campaigned on
ending our middle eastern wars and my
first executive order as president is to
blow up a bunch of kids that's what he
did
a village of women and children in
pakistan i believe john's right
and that's i remember it was like a
month and i was like yeah hope and
change and then i'm like let's see
what's going on
i voted for that whoa and then known as
everyone was gone and i'm like where
where everybody go
i kind of feel bad about this guys where
there's nobody left
all the activists were gone how about
the big stories that nobody is talking
about
that president trump is taking on big
pharma
i mean that is a giant story when has a
president
ever done that what's he doing well he's
trying to lower drug prices
so we can be competitive with canada for
example
and he also gave us the right to try
which was huge for
patients that are uh terminal
terminal and giving them the option to
try
uh a drug to see if it will save their
life i can't
i can't believe that wasn't already
available thank you so
so you know you know what this is like
let's say you're dying and the doctor's
like you're gonna die in six months
now there's a clinical trial right now
for this drug that might kill you too
but you can try it because you're gonna
die anyway so normally
like there's a ton of experimental
treatments there's a ton of treatments
that maybe haven't gone to human trials
right to try means if i'm gonna die
anyway give me that medication does that
entail psychedelics too
like mushrooms things that are you are
wearing a mushroom shirt but i cannot
answer that question
i hear that they're really good for end
of life patients i like how people deal
with
coming to terms with death and stuff
interesting what was that movie where
like the old dude's doing heroin because
he's like i'm 80 years old i don't care
a little bit sunshine or something and
then he ods oh that's terrible
i mean like you're on you're like if it
i look if you're dying
and you're old and you're not pain if
you should have the right
chance to save your life and so these
are the stories nobody's talking about
uh
veteran affairs and making it so you can
fire people if they're not doing their
job why do we not treat our government
like a business i don't get that
if you're not doing your job get the
heck out
and let's put in somebody that will
president trump allowed it so you can
fire people within the va
if they're not doing their job wow there
there's there there is uh
uh a challenge between how we run
businesses and how we run government
the challenge with businesses is that
they're in
in essence authoritarian right the boss
can say you know what you're gone get
out for one
for any reason for the most part we do
have a bunch of labor laws so it's not
completely
but the general idea is it's a private
company they can do what they want well
government has to have consent of the
governed so you end up
i think with you know these bureaucratic
systems i think the main problem is
we've been stacking laws upon laws upon
laws forever
and so now we have this giant ball of
sludge it's impossible to move through i
think that's been one of the biggest
hurdles for donald trump
is that he's used to running this
company where he can be like
give me the permits we're building a
golf course right over there it's gonna
be great
everyone's gonna love it then he gets
into government and he's like
i know exactly to solve this problem
he's like get me a national security
advisor we're gonna go through i'm sorry
sir we can't do that we have to go
through congress
first and then once we get approval wait
what how long is that going to take six
months
wow yeah so so one of the challenges
with the big pharma thing
is you're right he's trying but he's not
a king he can't you know he
he signed his executive orders to lower
prices and now i guess
some people i've seen report that
insulin prices have dropped quite a bit
happy pens have gone down
but when he goes to these debates
they're like you're not you can't do
that executive order can't even change
this you're you're making it up
and they're arguing he can't lower the
prices like what
can i guess i guess what trump did with
the executive order
which was within his powers is i'll open
up trade with other countries
so it's like in canada they get things
super cheap so says it fine
we won't buy from the big big pharma
that's jacking the price up on all these
from canada we'll get from canada so
that'll force them to lower their prices
precisely you know you know what i love
about this all this stuff
i i know so many people who are saying
things like can you believe trump was
putting you know tariffs on products and
starting a trade war and i was like oh
yeah yeah tell me why you're worried
about that
well i mean it's like bad like why is it
bad well because there's like a trade
deficit what does that mean
i just like trump shouldn't do it i'm
like oh you have no idea what you're
talking about okay
so i'll tell you what i saw this today
from gallup this is
this is one of the most shocking polls i
have seen yet in this cycle guess what
enthusiasm they say is very high right
for donald trump voter enthusiasm is
through the roof i mean people are
saying like i will crawl through you
know barefoot through broken glass to
vote for donald trump
enthusiasm for joe biden is non-existent
there's no one going like biden
they're mostly just like i hate trauma
but get this
gallup says enthusiasm is average
they do not expect high voter turnout
what based
yup but but think about what that means
if trump supporters are like frothing at
the mouth screaming like
i gotta go vote trump and they're like
jumping out windows and like superhero
landing and then running a million to go
to the
voting booth if the trump supporters are
extremely
active enthusiastic and ready to vote
but voter turnout's expected to be the
same
that sounds like trump's gonna win in a
landslide
maybe so so that's what it sounds like
you don't think so it's gonna we're
gonna have historically
high voter turnout but that actually
helps president trump i'm telling you
right now we're gonna have historically
high voter turnout
and we've seen it already and the amount
of ballots that have already been
returned in florida the early voting
going on in virginia
the amount of voter registrations that
are going on it's going to be
historically high
but that helps donald trump why does
that help trump we're seeing new voters
new people that have never voted in 56
years i get messages like that all the
time scott i'm in tennessee i'm 56 years
old i've never voted will you help me
register to vote yes i will
and i've seen that all across the
country now i know that's anecdotal but
people are slowing on james down
we we are seeing that the gop
is registering more voters than the
democrats yes and they're closing the
gap so
most most people probably don't know
this the republican party is much
smaller than the democratic party
and republicans tend to win because
independent voters will sw
will swing towards the republicans but
now we're seeing the gap closing
we're getting the gop in pennsylvania
for instance in
numerous places have closed the gap i
think by 160 000 registrations
they're uh and according to axios it's
not necessarily because of new voters
you know what's happening people are
leaving the democratic party
it's new voters too it is it is for sure
yeah trump lit up a bunch of areas that
had never voted before
yeah but it's significant to say many
democrats are walking away oh absolutely
look at the data
i mean pa is my wheelhouse and i'm
spending the entire month of october
in pennsylvania i'm actually heading
there tomorrow to doyle's town which is
bucks county
bucks county hasn't voted republican
since i believe
1988
and uh historically been democrat and
their voter registration numbers for the
republicans are through
the roof that is a bellwether look at
erie erie's another bellwether which
voted for donald trump in 2016. their
republican numbers are through the roof
allegheny county which is
pittsburgh pittsburgh which is basically
they always say pennsylvania
is philly and pittsburgh and then
alabama in the middle we're doing
really well with voter registration in
allegheny county so
uh the numbers don't lie arizona's
looking good which by the way the
democrats just
uh extended the voter registration to
october 23rd yesterday was the last day
by the way
florida they are desperate north
carolina
and pennsylvania were killing it in all
four states
so you're going on doing voter
registration oh yeah i'm doing voter
registration
sign waving door knocking phone banking
i will
do whatever it takes to win legally
that's what needs to happen man and then
you're going to sleep for five months
and then i will sleep
well depending on what happens on
tuesday november 3rd because if it is a
contested election
yada yada then which it probably will be
with
with maryland right like it's cool
because they're four weeks depends
so what i think michigan are they
waiting until the 10th
um well there's been some conflicting
stuff so like a federal judge
said something about like wisconsin or
one of those states or maybe maine
that you know they they have to be due
on election day so several
of the democrats plots to extend the
mail-in ballots are being shut down
which is great because ronald mcdaniel
has a i think it's protect the vote.com
and they're doing a good job suing the
democrats but uh
it it we need to vote overwhelmingly it
has to be an
overwhelming and resounding victory on
tuesday november 3rd 2020 and we not
only have to win the house but we have
to win the senate and dare i say
it would make us look much better if we
win the popular vote too you know so
those states like mississippi and
arkansas and south dakota
like your vote matters more because it's
going to go to the popular
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you